Monday Monday Monday back from Portland
days Euston I'm back from dolls all over
Texas bro I'm wearing Texas tuxedo right
now as the kids call it what does that
mean denim-on-denim
Texas tuxedo I didn't know that's what
it's called yeah I work for a reason to
throw okay I draw maybe to them like
look if this Texas I'm like this
yeah dad look amigo that's fancy so if
there's a horse saddled up icuidado you
just jump right on with no problem yeah
I want to tell you this on air cuz don't
know if you know this or not but shot
some guns with my boys out there well
you know I saw a baby I'm hyper but they
asked if I'd be this is awkward they
asked me who who is they
Matt best who was a special forces guy
yeah rest the back rifle coffee badasses
yeah said do you think you could go over
to Iraq and take care of a few things
now hold on Brennan I just have a little
trouble believing you what were the
couple things like what okay so you're
being general right now I'll say this
the ends with bark water
that sounds really close to Blackwater
you said it not me
or maybe it's dark Hatter I don't know
but either way I'm not good with puzzles
he not getting either home he's a park
Walker barcaro has black Jesus I was
terrible so I did shoot a bunch of crazy
guns um I saw you what was your favorite
was you what was the gun that you felt
you were the best shot at I think none
of the above
I'm not comfortable guns but uh Matt
best for when he was killing bad guys he
put together the exact same gun that he
would burst in the doors I kicked down
doors with and has like this [ __ ]
laser onto the screen I didn't m4s you
[ __ ] said yeah it's name for wood not
much recoil right oh they're really like
a video game yeah yeah and then some of
them I go to the big gun that had like
crazy kickback and yeah Jesus Christ
yeah Amy pistol you shoot that this was
a fifty caliber they had even bigger one
but the arrangement let us fire it and
back in all over one hand do it and he's
like here try it when he goes but you
know stay on it make because it fires up
heat and they show me videos of girls
and like smaller guys doing who should
ask themselves out I was laughing so
hard
that's I was kind of nervous that do it
I'm nervous around guns up I just
thought my life should be nervous it'd
be like if they came to the Jitsu mat
they'd be a little bit like you should
be nervous around guns when you're in
that range and you feel the force and
the power and the discount and you smell
the smoke it's it's we know what happens
to me when I'm in a firing range my back
seizes up my lower back discussed like
it's exhaust I get it I'm afraid the
whole time I'm just not familiar and
then I'd fire some I go god I can't like
I fire the big 50 caliber his gun no I
went god I can't believe people [ __ ]
it hit with these things I can't imagine
what I feel like and Matt goes oh you
won't have to it would just blow up that
done that 50 Cal blow your hole straight
through it latias oh yeah and you know
go up to a beer and shoot a [ __ ] that m4
you're shooting which is a modified m16
it's a shorter barrel that bullet
travels so fast that when it hits you
it's it does leave a big hole and the
other side and it's awful I like the
jargon they're talking about to like
they'd go back and forth like oh you
would use a 50 Cal with the 15a art and
that's like this yeah like in the middle
of a [ __ ] offense coordinator and a
defense gonna talk you know look what
the [ __ ] is happening right now it's
their language do you only tell my
shotguns I click on that one with all of
those big big guns
yeah that's Matt's the one up timeout is
Matt's gun on the that looks like I
modified he's it's custom made that he
was there's those are ar-15s they're
those are our salt rifles for sure but i
wonder i don't know and hey look at
these morons they feel finger off the
trigger until you rate of fire
geez I'm their Special Forces guys you
think they'd let me put my gun on the
trigger I'm like this yes guys yeah well
I took a picture like no no - hold on
and they're like you we don't want you
get critique is our fans are gonna see
this - you need and so my it looks like
I'm like this but if you look closer -
if you zoom in on that Genesis I'm like
this so you're not touching the hell ah
there we go
yeah hey you [ __ ] there with the
picture better monsters man they're
gonna let
get away with that keep your finger off
the trigger there's a human would be it
when I shot I shot guns every day for 12
days straight or something when my dad
took me too much fishing in Alaska but
after like 12 days shooting guns I was
shooting my friend this guy we met had
an arsenal he lived on on the on the sea
on in an inlet like I know houseboat
basically literally a houseboat sounds a
little crazy yeah oh yeah oh yeah and he
had a [ __ ] Arsenal and target set up
and then you throw [ __ ] in the water and
just shoot whatever and it gets after a
while you're just like dr. Isley but
then my dad had us some it's called I
think it's a 370 Winchester it's a it's
to kill elk and frankly you could
probably drop an elephant yeah it kicks
so hard in the guys that keep your mouth
open I was like what he goes they keep
your mouth over neither your ears
otherwise your ears will you know and I
was like oh but even outside when I
shoot it I was next to him my dad shot
that shot it kicked so bad that they
scoped hit him in the eye and he had a
[ __ ] round
yeah he walked around with a round you'd
hardly think how louder it was so loud
so not outside that I ran away I was
like dude it hurt my face so loud like
we had I'll on these ear things where
you can hear you know all that stuff but
if you'll have those on you'd be [ __ ]
so I was asking and for all those guys
who I came around after we shot our ear
things on cuz someone's firing I go dude
when we're at like warrior doing
operations how do you guys Ayers not
blow out and your thigh just told the
funniest dick joke of all time because
those hard good old boys are going all
right
but you see they showed me the exact
ones from military like these little
headsets with the voice things and he
goes you have operator the voice
airplane operated up here then you have
your ground control here he goes yeah
listen to both going through both it's
like yeah here's why you're moving Jesus
Christ Rogan had we went deer hunting in
Alaska and he had he unzips of course I
just used the rifle that whoever gives
me yeah you know of course somebody made
him or maybe he had this insane rifle
made I tell you know my joke it's like
made of ivory
dinosaur skin and the whole [ __ ]
thing and it was it the the guy said
well you got to stay over here because
if you stay I think in front of the the
chamber you can go deaf because even
outside you can go to Jack so I was
behind him and by the way the trigger I
shot it the trigger is so sensitive that
you could blow on it not not safe and it
was so [ __ ] loud it was it's like
guys can you I know you made this Hamid
gun can you would it kill you to do
something about the noise it's gas
escaping you know that's how a silencer
works apparently oh really
yeah weird so it's like a muffler you're
heard one they're not that size they're
not that time you and the movie salt
yeah yeah a 22 you can make really quiet
do not that quiet though like the movies
no they just like a 45 yes good it makes
nice laughs not but it's loud so you
would really know what it was like let's
hear it you can still turn your [ __ ]
head like crazy 22 sparrow from Silence
for captain ears and fire the goddamn
guns and so this is a he's going balls
deep in that go why did I suppress get
another one hey man shoot the guns by
the way let's go ahead and take this off
that's [ __ ] quiet a little bit really
quiet now that sounds like when I take
out that's what I use when I thought he
- bro I put them in a back pocket that's
a lot of different it's just one more
time say what our thoughts are rich one
more time get y'all's thoughts on them
put in your ear we're over glasses then
you have a little bit of leakage there
so you've got a quest with a Catholic
help when it's time to assassinate
somebody that's what you need to use man
1 trigger the guns are [ __ ] scary
some powerful [ __ ] yeah you can kill
from a distance that's what they say
that human beings once they learned how
to kill from a distance it was like just
being able to throw yeah and then then
creating weaponry that you that allowed
you to kill somebody hurl an object that
somebody from a distance and of course
Matt was like yet
fun man Matt Besler he runs on with your
schoolmates yeah oh dude before your
coffee launches while we come out here
go in Texas I noticed landowner with the
helicopter well let you drive the
helicopter will teach it really you're
not those guys there he goes we'll teach
you really fast you drive the helicopter
and then we'll hang out the back and
just shoot hot I think it's got a wet
live oh wow cool man
yeah let's do that yeah I'll fly the
chopper I went but with all the panel's
every aspect but I mean I've never flown
a helicopter before he goes easy man oh
okay okay how about while you guys gun
down I'll let you guys fly it and then I
like hang out in the back and watch
goddamn man those words I would like to
shoot pigs from helicopter one I just
did there are a nuisance
I don't you see it shall be a video and
Alex disturbing but then they told me
how bad the hogs are they're a major
pest you know the farmers are pay you to
go out there yeah let's see you got it
I mean cuz they got some problems
they're seeing this things fast
this is him just flying around yeah
let's look at the first one you imagine
me in a chopper come on do it slow oh oh
[ __ ] that's a big [ __ ] bore that just
ate a dirt nap down now was saying he
shoot like deleted like six bullets and
keep coming they said they're tough as
nails yeah wild boar that's a group of
them kind of sad too
Yeah right the stuff that's delicious I
would eat him that's the difference I'll
eat the [ __ ] out of a pig all the time
to see though yeah yeah all together
it's because they don't get it like what
the [ __ ] run man but they breed they
multiply like that some insane little
baby ones do that's the fastest [ __ ]
though dude yeah but they're marking
them down yeah that's a hard that's a
hard one look at how its weaving in and
out yeah oh damn good shot holy [ __ ]
well there it is hog hop looks ha got
Bullock oh my god ah Polly hog Olympics
now it was like this Ted Newton did this
show or else a pork ellipse he's like it
should be illegal not to do this
what happened that show I remarried do
like crazy [ __ ] yeah
um and then what's uh Henry Rowan said a
similar show well Ted Nugent has a huge
rain ranch he's a huge where he hunts
yeah you know his own meat oh I think
that's lying around there I would love
to eat like my own meat go out and shoot
my own dude I could live in Texas hell
yes I could live in Austin I yeah on our
breeze compound yeah I was uh I said the
coolest hotel I've ever been in San
Antonio really the best in San Antonio
dude you get on the waterfront on the
rip closed used to be an old brewery
really cuz I've not stated good best
house the best could it be hotter it by
the way in Texas could it be hotter you
so it was a little sticky yeah used to
melt your shoes so where were you okay
lemma let me see this thing
the boys that black raffle put me up
there Wow
damn I've never seen anything like it
Wow ever that's really cool leave them
like a new hotel no it's old its old
it's filled you City revamp did you sip
coffee or brandy like a gentleman I sip
coffee yeah sip coffee eight well damn
well you did yes and at that hotel
oh yeah that's not only I don't need at
the hotel so nice Wow
hotel Emma that's where I'll stay when I
go to some thoughts on Tony have you
done stance in today sure have really
well lol it's large Club is it a large
club yeah really Club oh [ __ ] it by
locusts locust got into the into the
[ __ ] Club yeah yes sir and I was hit
in my face and then in my leg but while
you're performing by a number of locust
yeah one goes that well see Brennan in
certain times in San Antonio like in
August the locusts the biblical locusts
come down to cleanse you know Texas of
its sins and you see locusts everywhere
I told you when I was in San Antonio and
it was August I went I was gonna walk to
the Starbucks and the woman said where
you going I said walk to Starbucks she
goes no you're not I said it's only
about a quarter mile away she was I know
you're not and I went out and I got
about eight hundred yards and I pride
myself on dealing with what the heat
terrible in the cold complete [ __ ]
longneck can't handle it yeah heat I'll
take it all yeah and I turned back
around oh and that's camel went back
inside this old camel said not a camel
cause remember I lived in Saudi Arabia
Philippines I was born there I got you
travel oh yeah look at that look at the
locusts can you eat them you can eat him
cover him in chocolate try them out
mm-hmm
they get big um yeah huge them so hot
we'd walk across to that Galleria Mall
and we would scurry and I saw some boys
playing basketball outdoors middle of
the day I'm like what the [ __ ] oh you
get used to it no I don't know I don't
know you know Iraq for a lot of those
soldiers they'd be in they be have their
vest on I've have all their ledger on
and their helmet phone by the way get
into a Hummer Lillian and there's no air
conditioning of course tour that
it's no joke nightmare yeah the heat I
look good when I'm watching you do well
in the heat no I hate you're from Texas
bro that's what I hated about Texas
everything else I loved you miss it huh
you were from Texas
well sorta from where is yeah like you
from the Philippines Wow
well you guys won't know it's so temple
and clean area it's probably an hour
from Austin or Dallas yeah price off
okay
now you could live in Austin when you
say taxes um you enjoyed the shopping in
Houston a lot of money besides LA New
York Houston's write up well remember
there's a lot of money I always forget
the Dallas in Houston that's our [ __ ]
load of money stupid money went to a
wine shop just like a regular wine shop
and I was looking at once and their
wines that were like three four or five
hundred dollars I was like who the
[ __ ] afford this oh it's oil maan oil
boys yeah hello boys
yeah I could live there for sure the
amount of land you can get there's good
food the people are cool I like the
people
dude there's more guns than [ __ ] who
knows how many guns are intact yeah I
feel safer there than anywhere that's
right because if a spree shooter opens
up got lots like my boy [ __ ] Earl
over there with his goddamn sick shooter
in his pockets happen there are a lot of
examples of a guy came into a coffee
shop tried to shoot it up in Texas not
if he got dropped then there was a guy
was a there was a County Fair and these
two dudes three dudes got out of their
cars to shoot it up no they were I think
they were affiliated with Isis they got
dropped yeah
Texans are got like what up but also no
one's in a rush either like when I Drive
in LA or wherever the hell I'm at
Florida if I rent the car you know about
8590 down them up them freeways yeah in
Texas you can't cuz everybody nice and
easy
there's no rush baby that's right this
lords lords land
it's almost its own country there's
always been really it's not even quiet
movements for Texas to kind of secede
from the union you know California that
for you when the vote is but they're
breaking up in a northern Cal California
Southern Cal well there's more the Cal
is all for it cuz there's so much money
like we're sick of you guys feeding off
the tee yeah well there's no do our own
there's a there's a Republican and
there's your eye for rice most
successful economy in the world if they
do that that's what crazy is that yeah
all the silver yeah it was very
important city now to but yeah not
compared to them boy
nerds Tim nerds them nerdy nerds
nurdinez and no you know Jay the
penny-pincher yeah he uh
I said hey up they booked a hotel him I
just get a hotel there Jay booked hotel
for $79 and said good reviews $79 and he
goes I can't stay here you know you know
it's bad Jay staying some [ __ ] Jay
asleep on the studio c'mon Snickers once
you save money up and he goes I can't
stay here I said I'll get you no world
we'll figure it out come here they come
to those wall did he stay with you can't
have that I would rather pay the money
which wasn't cheap to get him his own
room
can't have doors like a grizzly bear he
does we gotta get that taken care of no
man can't snore it'll affect your sleep
according to Matt Walker who wrote that
book why we sleep that's a sleep guy the
guy Rogan yeah yeah problem with that
guys no he's great now I got a podcast -
I love sure didn't hear it I got a
problem with him why just because he's
saying this belittle amount of sleep if
you don't get it that's like the end of
the world now everyone's all worried and
[ __ ] it relax has a problem we know
sleeps important but he's like you know
you get 400 sleep you think you're make
it up the next day doesn't work like
that yeah yeah well the truth is you
know him I go we've all had to function
on four hours of sleep the but besides
that I did not yeah exactly the science
just says that you should get seven
tonight
for sure I should also beaten how many
veggies so you've said like one before a
UFC fight you can't [ __ ] sleep and
they'll tell you it's fine you know if
you saying it's nothing
yeah but he said it's not you know
because you're nervous the next it's the
day before that you need your sleep but
everybody can can power through a
[ __ ] a day with little sleep you
you've all done the world has to the
world has to and there are a lot of
people that just that function on six
hours of sleep five hours late yeah he's
saying even those people go I only need
four hours like not true well you talk
to those people
no he's right in other words they can
draw it's very tight correlations
between cardiovascular disease cancer
and for sure and outside and I can sleep
for sure yeah but I'm sure just the same
way you can find a lot of people who
probably their heart
missions are just fine and they're doing
very well so he says that there's a
there is a gruesome there is a
population a subset of the population
that can that can achieve what they call
wakefulness at five hours of sleep there
are some people like I'm sure a lot of
those Special Forces guys like with the
SEAL training when you're not sleeping I
think that's part of weeding out the
sort of group that can't deal with it
but also that just an altimeter body
adapts your body well adapt yeah love
though he would although social forces
in military those guys might be a lot of
those guys might already have that gene
so I don't think all of them I think I
think there's also ability to over day
you ain't do it that people can do
there's moms at work you know [ __ ]
[ __ ] our jobs and they adapt to it you
know yeah but you still how you say it's
not ideal well life isn't it but people
who adapt like so so the people that
adapt at work night shift and stuff like
that they still have higher institutions
knowledge it so your body is basically
genetically made to sleep in the mouth
for sure but I wonder if you have to
take on that work schedule but your diet
was on point if you'd still have all
those problems just all those people
have those problems because they're
surrounded by junk food sure certain
other things well the others a lot of
other things that go into that bad I
would imagine you would need less sleep
probably if you ate really clean but um
that your brain apparently has a sewage
system yeah so that you when you sleep
you clean your brain and that's kind of
interesting
now see here The Rock says he sleeps on
a three to five hours a night you know I
don't know those guys like that man yeah
I'm sure I don't sleep although they say
they say not Rogan sleeps though I've
been with him but they say that that
Michael Jordan slept for five hours but
that's a bad example you're talking
about an extreme you're talking about a
physical phenom anyway my buddy
yeah my buddy who is uh like the just
the biggest freak I've ever seen
physically he will I he was my roommate
he really only needed four to five hours
and he's 50 now he still only needs that
there are some people that just don't
need as much sleep but did slim to
vanishing that jock though right yeah
that's a good example 46 all he needs
less sleep but [ __ ] off with your 4:30
a.m. wake up [ __ ] off I can't do it he
posed to look you post everyday Oh slap
dead
6:00 a.m. get up at 5:30 I got you jack
oh hey 16 when you get jobs on this
[ __ ] show let's get him on what
happened to a Ken Jeong
what do you mean I thought you guys know
ask Ken Jeong to be on the show I got
the Korean guy I know I get me help me
the other day what's gonna wat ya I love
ya oh well this should be enough - dude
um how's the show well his gun Julianne
Cecily brought the old 10-minute pod
unbelievable is so funny Celia Julia got
in this whole kick about how he has a
Starbucks in this house because it's
house is so big and II didn't realize
they set one up and then he was like and
then it turned out that it was a
whites-only Starbucks was just whites in
it I was like well is there a sign he
goes well it just says you know we
refused to reserve the right to refuse
service to anyone then they're on there
there was like really small lettering
what'd it say well it said again I don't
know if this is all new I didn't know
and he's like what it's saying is well
it said no dude that's a racist
Starbucks and then it turns out the guy
who was the older guy was dressed like a
Klan memory have his head brilliant a
robot funny men [ __ ] lives to be fun
in Portland yeah well when it's fun but
I don't drink wine anymore I'm on a very
strict diet right dude I can't tell how
many people cut me go tell Brian
couldn't [ __ ] with his diet whatever
size you guys I used this lotion and
it's [ __ ] gone everybody everybody's
got put banana peels on you know me you
know me people hit me up
try banana peels try CBD oil try them
it's a thousand things I'm working with
a guy who's a real scientist I'm good
let me see your legs that's not good
let's stop working with him hey I just
started doing it [ __ ] off I just anyone
who goes do just change your diet no I
just whatever you're doing is no word I
haven't done it yet I've just started is
he giving you actually this is bad
because I your choices I've
I know because I ate a bunch of [ __ ]
well I thought you said you didn't know
I'm just starting this now I Jimmy
what's the new diet just no alcohol like
we thought he was always on a new diet
alcohol crates yeast I got a lot of I
got all my tests back am I like all I
did everything from cortisol to testan
but no medication how was your test
hello what was it
lately recently so there's there's
there's free testosterone that you lose
and then there's the testosterone it's
in your body's white levels when you do
a level it wouldn't mean anything to you
but it's low it like I don't remember
the reading but my free testosterone and
I felt it in the past
that is low yeah because a lot of it has
to do with your gut too like my cortisol
levels really high and my my melatonin
levels are really low so I'm at a five
melatonin 18 is low and I'm at five I
don't sleep well because my cortisol
levels are really easy sleep you get
sleep not really I don't look down the
road you I mean if you get into if you
really get into it like if you look at
the my gut bacteria and stuff like that
that can put you in a state of stress
that can elevate your cortisol levels
and keep you don't think it's because
everything you have going on
maybe it might be part of that this this
bed of a problem no it might be part of
it it kill unity take a pill scientist
you can take Humera and you can take
biologics and they and that increases
your risk for cancer know that you but
that's like we're so amazed you know
where it's like no I don't know
ompletely different it's totally
different
I've looked into this when you take
Humera ready for this you can't get life
insurance my dermatologist ghost you can
take Humera but I have two patients one
who got lymphoma and the other one who
got looper on that
yeah it's so is lowers it takes out
inflammation it manipulates certain like
so the only thing it brings down it also
lowers your immune system so Lily yeah
they don't surprise this is a very
tricky [ __ ] disease but you're right
when stress and a lack of sleep like
good sleep has a direct effect on it so
does your so does according to the lay
its scientists your gut hell I think you
got a before you shoot you're supposed
to gotta quit going on the roads
I'd stay around town I all him to
ominous okay I have two more road keys I
got Tampa and then I have Syracuse oh
those are close
did you call Justin oh hey man no I need
as far as possible
well the shake a template then series
well what's good about sirak is you got
to take four planes than a boat and in
the air there's I'll chop up built a
tunnel that you have to crawl under and
then and then by the time you get there
you're older because it takes over but
then also the best thing about it too is
it's connected to a mall so then you
really healthy because the only thing
that's open that late would be a
cheesecake I can't wait for that because
I'll tell you this what's good about
that also is that I have to my let's see
July I think its sixth and seventh is
the gig so I should probably take a
plane now just to make sure I get there
on time the other thing that's gonna be
good for you too because you don't have
any UFC fans is you're doing the biggest
you see of the year so that's Saturday
skip what do i watch DC vs. t pay or
don't see Bryan Callen yeah that's a
good well I like to I like to just
really push myself but it doesn't matter
because I'm getting ready to shoot my
special so I'm working on my it's not
two nights it's Friday Saturday it'll be
fine yeah I don't I can't wait for that
fight I might I might miss my own show
to watch that fight no how about one guy
goes dude Dave Chappelle and Jon Stewart
are there performing the same night as
you man it okay goes I just do I go see
Dave Chappelle and Jon Stewart or I go
you're showing it you go see that you
you go see them matter of fact I might
cancel my Saturday there myself
yeah different demo Jon Stewart I'm are
seeing Jon Stewart in 1909 t 8 when he
was doing stand-up before he had the Jon
Stewart Show and and I saw him many
times he loves he'd be sitting there in
a club he'd show up and he was as good
as anybody's ever lived
Jon Stewart was he's an amazing stand-up
comic I'd love to see what him and uh
Dave Chappelle stand-ups like together
like he opens up remember I used to
watch Dave Chappelle I did shows what
Dave Chappelle when he would get up and
even back then people were like aw Dave
Chappelle like he would get up and you
know and then Pete demson open for him
that's a hell of a show man yeah Jon
Stewart just a goddamn legend
he's just he's never been bad he's never
done anything he's never not anything
really yeah
The Daily Show unbelievable he's just
he's just awesome in every way did they
name the towards it just the Chappelle
and Stuart door ah I get a sense that
Jon Stewart is such a decent human being
like in every way like he's so
thoroughly can like ethically and
morally consistent don't you feel that
way like he's just such a good guy go
and be strenght oh I want to be his
running - I'd love to be his friend they
did I afraid they did a play to be one
soccer did you know I like a like it's
the place only held like 6k I thought it
told more than that
Stuart played d1 soccer oh yeah smart
financial Wow I'd love to see that
they're nowhere near they know they
don't have to see that - is that it
that's it no they're only doing Boston
Houston and El Paso Texas
let me see Eric Bana maybe four let's
look at the tape ticket please nothing's
on sale yet so my boyfriend Jared Leto's
here at the Forum July 19 you're gonna
go there rubberband your [ __ ] enemies
Adam I'm gonna have to tie down my love
you
Jared Jared no interesting us today Eric
Bana what you said I just saw that he's
doing a new series I just like one of
those guys I thought it was awesome I
mean I just I'd love to see those two
though since they announced it but
there's no way that's it
it says few exclusive dates so that's
probably it damn yeah and Johnston
there's nothing in LA where Stewart
lives he's a New York guy huh yeah
that's it
well I think so he's been in New York a
long time the only time to see him we've
been when I was in Houston
ain't that a [ __ ] Sonic just like it
flight El Paso
let me jump in Delp that's what a weird
way to go where is El Paso Austin
Houston you named the collagen El Paso
know the UTEP miners I think it is
really University of Texas
El Paso you wouldn't like me as I was I
was in the elevator coming up here and a
giant blonde man just a giant and I
looked at him and I just like oh you
suck him off he's so big I go play
football because yeah I go worry goes
Texas A&M I was like what you Plagueis
defensive end tight in time I went what
was his name plate tryout for the pros
you guys yeah I played Arena League then
I tried out for the Browns and didn't
work out
GG his name no I was just a giant blond
guy like a Justi like clop but with he's
put on some weight
yeah I think it's the it's UTEP I think
their names the minors we played them in
a Utah you tap man University of Texas
El Paso it stands for alright I'll take
a hand chins face yeah yeah I heard
without a mascot probably it lobster
should stay on the right there does it
gin I'm awesome
it's the miners an oyster why don't they
have an oyster as a mask leader Pete
just an oyster and the mascot just sits
there and Fester's a little bit opens up
every now and then yeah and then
somebody eats it and then throws up or
dies of food poisoning once aggressive
yep my nurse guy fuckin'-a that's the oh
there you go now being a mascot would be
since remove my son decides he wants to
be a mascot don't come home or to play
the tuba in the high school band
too bad I'm for that I would prefer it
but I'm going to discourage both I may
have to strike him now after here's a
good chance if your son's the mascot he
plays the big flute Brian you think so
oh dude is that is that typically what
gay men are drawn to science bro why do
you have whole mod you're telling me
that if you're a mascot and you liked it
you wear foam heads and you you dance
around that you're now you said if
you're a male cheerleader I can
understand kind of being like woo kind
of but but but I'm sorry sir it's
science man I don't yeah you don't you
know rock rocky for the Nuggets yeah
sucks that means dick hard rock you know
that dude you're being there that's
science I don't know if it is dude
you're just you can can't you be
straight and be a mascot ring roll
scientist on your podcast ask them well
can't you be kind of a like do
a little bit of a dork I've never been a
guy who's like that much into a team and
that cheery you know he's cheery yeah
but you're hidden underneath there so
you get away with love what kind of
money those guys make all been millions
and Bank bro hey but I mean it is
interesting we sign mascots gonna fight
no fights Gugu YouTube mascots get in
fights why would you be a mascot that
there's gotta be a lot of anger behind
that one I'd love to I would love for a
therapist sit down with ten mascots
yeah you're so hot so you know rocky
from the Nuggets got paid bank he was a
number one mascot in the NBA I didn't
know he's getting paid serious money
look at this this is obviously fake
another some real ones go the best
mascot fights go back don't ever go to
fake when he do very funny really fight
the I've seen one where they're like
serious yeah that's incredible
it's not pretty sure is college
sometimes you see those NASCAR guys
mascot fight compare accomplished yes
those NASCAR boys to throw down I'll
throw it out that these not many fakes
yeah [ __ ] it chin yeah dinger suck you
off right though I just feel like you're
making that up Brennan dude dang you're
a suck you off no don't say that you
don't know about dinger is dinger his
name yeah ding responds names dinger
dude look at look into it what's your
name bro damaging yeah ah I was a big
purple dinosaur there's my dick big
purple dinosaur yeah suck on them Rocky
Mountain Oysters stop I don't like when
you like you always do every podcast
what do you mean
sock [ __ ] why do you like that I don't
know how'd you break things bro good man
my teeth how come they're not Airy
they are let me see the bottoms bro the
top I don't worry about coming to got
one still like yo wow the rest more like
getting my soul someone back that one
goes yo he's fallen in line he's kind of
he's the Rose apart have you're talking
to wait til I'm done with these door Oh
devious he is not back to the bus not up
in there yep and he's and he's fighting
not up in here he's fighting to get in
the front
nope yeah little prod you I well I don't
know how yellow there I claim I cleanse
them today I'm pride that drinking
cherry retreat huh
it's kombucha bro no sugar hey Nico I
liked how sugar bros at our Booch better
hooch man it says better boot I know I
said better hookahs but drinking some
Booch hooch better who lucha um it's up
bro you got a got an audition I'm gonna
help you with I know we can't say what
it's for long I know but you got to play
a guy who's a tough but afraid kind of
I'll send you the skip I know what it is
and you want to try it now act like
you're tough no yeah I can't like here's
my money not doing it man just go I
don't know again trouble I know we're
just [ __ ] go I don't know I don't
know that's good where's my money I
don't know can you do a little breathing
before that where's my money
well I breathe hard anyway but just go
breathe in before that let me hear it
where's my money I don't know can you do
a little like stutter breathe where's my
money I don't know can I said the
chrisley I said every time you see me I
hear this he's good he's just in awe of
me how about what whenever I buy shoes
did I send you picture than issues about
yeah they they made me so angry I said I
showed I showed Stevie those shoes TV
blue eyes I showed I was like Jesus
Christ worse faster between you and
Stevie though well Stevie just very
simple both you're very sim we bought
that I sent it to uh meet whenever me
and Delia are new towns we say each
other's like shopping or whatever he's
like how's the shop and bro I'm all
amazing this can't wait they're in two
weeks so I go to Webster she goes done
look at those shitty shoes why did you
get those are those Reeboks seriously
what are they those are off lights what
does that mean off light Virgil okay now
now let me break this down when you see
those shoes let's be serious
I got rock-hard but i but they're did
why because if the tick-tack-toe thing
because I love the tic tac toe thing I
like the the light on I liked how
exclusive they are how where I get
what's a see the tag what the
[ __ ] is that tag doing broths the
off-white some keep that on keep that on
that's so annoying man you don't think
those look though I'm there so it's so
annoying Chinna I'll let you have a
[ __ ] get that tag off tag you didn't
slip that off oh my god and I'll watch
and then you and then the white laces
that are all God
ah and then you just have them you got
that big lip yeah like a big shield and
you just like the way that looks huh I
like what do you do you watch the way it
kinda you graduated into your [ __ ]
genes that you roll up now I am I'm
getting there and I don't the Texas boys
I was gonna have a hate crime I was sure
I heard a lot of I would knock her get
out of here boy we'll watch kinda round
out that my kind those shoes cuz you
don't know those shoes that you should
kind of be thrown on a flying headlock
it me if you weren't so tough I would do
it on principle I know I'd kick you
right in the [ __ ] ass I don't have
one friend who can beat me up I know I
wish I could beat you up cuz I'd kick
you good too I wish I could just give
you a fight and then I it'd be worth
really tussling up cuz no issues I go I
could be I gotta go
nope dude again I guess I'd kick you
right in the ass you need to start on
TRT
no your vote s no I'm just gonna change
it uh in sixty days we'll have a car top
oh she keeps going down I'll show you
the whole exclusive style keep going
keep going
there's a show for shoes I post it just
so people can educate themselves one
though uh nope keep going
those are new Puma Club keep going they
just got released you'll see keep going
if I really scrolled this page keep
going
there there that's a different style
CC's now I'd be I would buy you some
just so no I don't ever wear them [ __ ] I
would not fifty one wearing duo you're
special you tell me if you came out in
the water sold people want to go insane
we'll leave the red tag on let's say
off-white they go why is that fifty
one-year-old wearing wearing candy on
his feet no you have your outfit picked
out no I mean
I know what do you think I should hey
man
no stop stop laughing at me I need to uh
what would you stop my outfit big dumb
predisposed already what would you see
what would you suggest I wear I need
it's probably some good shape and
underwear call yourself
dick boy all right I like that bad to
the bone er that was funny that you had
bad to the bone er that's a new shirt um
that's a great shirt what it's a great
shirt
maybe maybe we should make an American
boner shirt just for the [ __ ] of it well
for your special I was gonna bring a
bunch of the one love shirts which are
selling like hotcakes great for sure
don't call you special one love or
American boner I won't not a big deal
I can't what is she gonna do one loves
funny one love it but that's you man I'm
gonna call one love bad idea it's not
bad idea I like American boner I got
skin it like yeah you know I get it
the fans demand it but that's our
friends they're gonna watch anyways yeah
you trying to be mainstream
yeah you have this Sean nbnbc right I
keep [ __ ] honest ABC god dammit
you've shown ABC American boners might
be a little too much maybe no I love it
please wrong will make American boner
shirts yeah I think we should make it
one love that you I think we should make
American boner shirts for sure for the
for this special you I mean when we go
there on in Chicago okay we have one we
can do one love I think we should sell
American boner shirts I think we should
launch him Network let's get a good
American boner shirt say no more film
right yeah and we've never had better
artist than we have net right it's not
bonfire yeah yeah um what can I wear I
need your help right now
t-shirt I think you should go black
shirt I got soft black shirt and some
light colored jeans and dry charging and
dark shoes not like soup those are too
dark with a budget really okay you Bruce
Wayne well well it's the summer too it's
a summer so black shirt so I don't sweat
you don't see this way great idea sweat
yeah I move around a lot yeah black
shirt t-shirt t-shirt okay black tea and
some nice jeans and then some then I
then I'd wear some I'd get some black
common projects or some low tops comm
projects don't support my
a little bit more athletic than common
projects you know I'm saying you feel
more athletic yeah like that I got a
nice athletic shoe that can exact that
that supports my feet
can I wear those like I'm sorry what I
did assumes I had some there's some
black adidas that are sweet yeah go
shoot shopping if you want let's go
shopping what
let's go shopping all right I'll be your
designer hey give me credits on your
suppose yes I swear does that be
hilarious outfit by Sean that'd be great
yes please I swear to God I roll all
right let's do it that's actually a
great idea fun stylist Brendan Schaub on
this trip you'll get your first [ __ ]
credit as stylist yes my hair up like a
quarter career begins yeah gonna be
adorable she's gonna be fun um look at
Kevin with the gold chain god I wish we
were a chain like that
I looked up Kevin stylist last night
yeah he's [ __ ] dressed so well man I
see that see though there you go there's
your outfit not that long of a shirt or
chalk there you go I see I see you're
saying though the jeans are a little
they're bluer yeah they're bouquet not
so dark all right I like that yep that's
your like what you're saying yeah that's
it show you some sick like boost some
some adidas boost we'll go to diaz Vanko
yep there you go I love it in the
business socks okay it out Addie's boost
we got those jeans that right there who
what's wrong with that nothing I got a
little while to get my arms that
muscular yeah he's got he's been working
out his style I looked up his stylist
she's pretty cool I'm liking that real
simple I like that a lot James purse has
some good black shirts see what happens
with that yeah night well genius boost
it's good they got a they got a solid
black they have all black I like that
yeah I'm going to buy those let's do
that be perfect yes styled by shot solve
that probably how about my dad sent me
that Father's Day card oh it's not great
I loved it let me see you don't see it
you should post what is it your dad sent
you a Father's Day card no my dad goes
you did this when you were eight to show
like whatever
just being silly creative when I was
eight huh well the guys dressed like my
dad was going I screwed ito just I love
Cruz it's a little racist let me say a
really good drawing for a year old right
yeah bring this up okay so you later
since you're already smoking a cigar
that's really good with a bird look at
the bird do you paint do you draw yeah I
used to draw all the time you did right
if you remember for the what about it
for the lifetime that I was doing you
got a you got a sperm whale look at this
okay so he's got the picture is of this
Mexican looking guy and they saying
later Senor he's grinning with a curly
mustache a hat that says justice and in
San Lucas I met these guys look at it
you've got a you got a purple parrot you
have a sperm whale that's pink a pink
sperm whale let me see them I was gonna
say you got a beautiful swin surfer
mm-hmm a multicolored win server and
then a dragonfly hmm that looks so
professionally done I can't even take it
it's like a collage and then you have
vacation time in bright yellow and pink
yellow and pink where your colors you
have a flamingo I like standing on one
leg that's weird you have a lizard a
gecko and you have a butterfly like to
hope you have your little hope they cam
vacation time hope you have fun your
little Li oh hello buddy was right
before those little now I think you were
probably 19 here and you're saying you
were young because there's no way that
an 8 year old did this so I'm gonna say
that you were I'm gonna say you were 15
years old
no definitely not and somehow I don't
know how it happened but somehow at 15
somebody shamed you into thinking that
you're straight and and now you've been
pretending ever since how did you do
these are just like stickers or stickers
okay this is actually really good right
at 8 for 8 yeah that's really good said
you do this when you're 8
so no one believed me I could draw Wow
my dad just randomly sent that yesterday
the face is really good it really is
later senior I mean the cigar is
outstanding
he's biting on the cigar yeah that's
actually a good detail teeth are perfect
to your little buddy Brent little for
all those little easy little yachty yeah
little brand [ __ ] guys got small wrists
and giant fingers really no I couldn't
couldn't have button his buttons with
those fangs now my signature is way
better when I was eight than it is now
miss I know I was eight back then
because if you go to that other picture
eyes ain't chin the back right sign I
did number 55 I was 55 in Little League
football
you got a hammock there the colors of
the gay flag thing made by just in case
my dad was wondering who made by Brennan
sharp and then the gay flag the great
gay pride
number 55 gross what was 55 for peewee
football jr. sale oh wow [ __ ] y'all I
don't know why he didn't play linebacker
silly chin what'd you do this weekend
chin Oh chin you launched your YouTube
page and jegos man Chin's page keeps him
more popular he's just gonna take off
and fire kid I'm like good chance J good
chance no I sent you a song to sing I've
been balls deep in country lately oh
yeah you sent me a Mercy Mercy Mercy no
have you heard written in sand mm-hmm
dude written in sand you need to sing
that one country artist let's hear it
Oh written and Sam it's not written on
paper but written on Sam's right Old
Dominion yep not written on a tree but
yeah I mean we can't play a I'll chop
this up so you can listen to it not
written on the smaller you back
[Music]
he's from Armenia that guy is he he
looks like huh and you won't say the
words and I want but you flirt when you
drink me Cowboys getting a Skeksis these
days right a well dressed and groomed
[Music]
can you do this one chin yeah but
doesn't sound that you're not feeling it
Namie where's he go to dan dan + Shay
tequila that's my second favorite song
right now you know [ __ ] about country
but I have your hey guys it's already a
not not like huge they see and share the
biggest right now the number one album
in the country wow you have you heard
this um I probably did but let me see
can you sing this one I feel like a
country music lyrics are so much better
than everyone else they're very they're
very literal it's all about a lot of
metaphor about getting [ __ ]
they tell stories they really do look
pretty those are my favorites not a lot
of poetry it's not what I metaphor it's
pretty direct I was sitting in the truck
you wouldn't look at them method I like
them I mean that's what I like I knew
from the day you said you me my girl and
we were gonna be together we're best
friends like white on rice
I've heard this one I love this sold-out
country
dude this time I could hop it's the
number-one country out amazing world pop
I disagree
it sounded more country now yeah that is
country as [ __ ]
I'm it's not in court brother tasty Kia
baby I still see ya oh my god don't do
that there's a line gets in the way
every time I try out of seeing us do it
kind of some about your braces but I
just want to say hey hey I'm 51 I
finally decided to get my tea straight
if they when I look in the mirror
it's a nightmare baby I'm when I'm a
good-looking guy until I smile up take
my shirt and pants off you're just okay
you're just okay cuz you hear us yelling
see ya
is that a red spotted leopard lady of
red spots all over your legs UT throttle
on the leper Bryan Callen spotted is he
a leopard or a leper I'm just probably
I'm proud that one tooth is like nah I
think ones like y'all write a song
called psoriasis
now that's arrived a song that says not
up in hearing just about that one tooth
who's not having it now my tooth is
coming but tooth is falling in line no
it's a trouble he's fighting never ever
the resistance people the love resists
own teeth refused to get him I got one
holdout in the bottom of my mouth one
holdout in the bottom of my mouth he
says nope nope nope nope nope nope skins
will stand silver BM yeah that is that's
the worst I've ever seen you like that's
a bummer
it's alright that's not don't snot on my
scalp yeah their face oh my god I would
pay money to have your face covered like
that so what would you do be in trouble
have to wear makeup dude how [ __ ]
shitty Oh that'd be fun get your big
break and your
spin-off Joe sorry you guys face covered
in spots yeah and ABC goes
to do this men we're gonna have to
replace you without spots don't show me
that [ __ ] I know I don't want to just
want to see if it exists I don't see my
face ever chin that's his future no what
would you do if they're like hey man
this there's no other there's no easy
way to tell you this but uh I want to
tell you in person I come back to stand
up runnin nope we price you told you
weeks ago I go back to doing what I do
anyway all the spots we can't have it we
found a replacement who is it was found
this guy is this big guy days breath why
this is perfect
I'd be like I'm happy for you on YouTube
chin uh I don't think so nothing new no
just that when a man was the one was
that's last one
chin trying to you famous on a zombie a
change fiendish mm-hmm you create him
fatness oh yeah well you didn't you
didn't talk about the kratom on this
show yet right oh I'm off good yeah
entirely it's what caused the vertigo oh
really yeah you sure about that really
mmm the only thing I added in my diets
it's the only thing that's new and if
you overuse it that's one of the side
effects Wow
I was using every day and every day and
I miss it and so I can't use anymore
this is awesome you got it you have you
have drug addict tendencies mmm but I
know like that was like when I got sick
there's nothing listen being high on
kratom is great being sick is way worse
yeah I'll take being normal yeah yeah
that's all it took that's right little
vertigo I make you sober oh [ __ ] yeah oh
my god bro Vertica sucks terrible
everything is dizzy I had a weird I had
a [ __ ] I was having dinner this is 20
years ago at my buddy Jed's house with
his parents and I don't know what
happened but as how has hit dinner
it looks like the jug of water was about
to fall I went whoa and my buddy said
you know my dad just wanted you to know
that later on he goes you know um
you know that if you're doing drugs or
anything like that there's help out
there like they thought I was high
because it wasn't moving yeah and I
don't know what happened it was an
optical illusion my eyes played a trick
on me yeah that does happen though
[ __ ] weird it doesn't happen to you
never like you think you're gonna hit an
awesome deserted in a [ __ ] desert I
haven't had water in seven days and I
see like a mirage or some [ __ ] but never
had a see well this was in the desert
and I had been oh okay that's not a
force my age thought it was a unicorn
they say that those ultra marathoners
like hallucinate oh that one on rodents
you saying she sees stuff all the time
like cats talk cuz she hasn't slept and
stuff yeah she started having a wake
dream yeah damn good stuff that must be
good for you keep running she's a badass
she can like run fat farther than any
man a lot of badasses yeah so what'd you
do this weekend she just uh I was
working on some more videos for chin Kim
stuff for the tube or the YouTube
channel for your huge channel really
defect kid stuff
there's a bunch really a lot of time
machine stuff alright yeah what's it you
know the stuff that mean last time the
chin cam we just followed you guys would
you guys went to shows and stuff over
here there's like five hours of stuff
I'm shooting ridiculousness on Friday
I suppose I want to go if they if it's
possible I don't see why not
it's that so gone don't season 12 damn
shooting two episodes if I could go a
definitely like Netflix er system take
an MTV and call me central and so many
different networks I've been like take a
seat take a seat you know I mean a
little bit yeah hmm so nothing's
changing faster than our business I feel
like you know entertainment yeah I mean
it's it's just like you have to continue
to you know adapt it's too much good
content out there I don't think with
podcast so this is my personal opinion I
think a lot of people would agree to you
that they like it to be this way yeah
like if you start adding a lot of crap
to it it's not as you know make it all
like all sorts of 360 view and all that
[ __ ] it might be Tommy yeah that might
help
yeah but as long as it's more as as real
as possible not like overly produced
yeah people want raw yeah
but it is almost like as technology
becomes more you know pervasive and
stuff and better there's still like this
idea that people like a lot of
restaurants are now like the ty n
restaurants the chef's go and forage for
the food like their own mushrooms and
area also it's like this well they've
been doing that but also in LA there's
no cell phones in the restaurant yeah
you get discount on your bill if you
don't use your cell phone
yeah or they just don't allow cell phone
yeah it's very kawaii Padma yeah I think
concerts and stand-ups should do that i
given Contador stand up should get rid
of from it really yeah it bugs me when I
see somebody filming my [ __ ] yeah like I
see that all the time I'm like you know
we're gonna do put it on YouTube you
know just I'm convinced you I do man the
first one I know you guys heard of this
already
Michael Rapaport essentially running
over to stop someone from opening an
airplane door that would be barring the
flight that would be Mike so don't know
about this no this is true that's true
because there's witnesses they said I'm
saying I didn't I didn't hear about oh
yeah yeah but however did you know this
that you can't open it during flight
what do you you can't open them or so
it's impossible don't yeah yeah that
that that you might wanna look that up
Jim but that's what I was told by
someone who flies for United because I
went when I was on my flight I said
something to the lady I went oh how
about that crazy person tried because
you how about the Chris British tried
open emergency do I go I know my boy
stopped and that's a good friend of mine
my crap porn she goes yep she was but in
fire way at it cuz even a guy your size
can open that during mid-flight it's
impossible
she just why would they make it that
easy to do you kill the whole [ __ ]
plane yeah she was it's impossible to do
mid-flight yeah there was a defensive
end played in the NFL for a long time
who try to do it he got up and he had a
psychotic incident he's like six foot
you know seven and he was huge and he
tried to open nobody and everybody's
like you got this giant was having a
psycho psychotic in and and he couldn't
know the planes are gonna put that much
faith in humanity that people are gonna
open that [ __ ] up otherwise Isis so what
it might do hello God
stop the guy I'm not sure what exactly
Mike do oh so it says it's like a
thousand pounds to pull it so just the
the pressure alone it's pretty much
impossible but there's got to be tons of
locks and stuff
yeah there's locks and safety so you
can't just open it like a [ __ ] though a
guy was trying to open it he thinking it
was a bathroom door but no one knew what
this at the time so Michael ran up to
him and said this what the [ __ ] are you
doing and the guy was like genuinely
confused so after the interview room
later on he's just a guy I'm guessing
he's probably like a a foreigner maybe
an Asian dude or something that had just
no idea where the oh so he wasn't like
gay dude Mike was like Moo Scott right
now I'm like [ __ ] them up no slaps what
the [ __ ] you do yeah and the guys like
oh I didn't know its rapport I'm out
here you know we had a [ __ ] incident
on the plane
big baby fake rock
he's with the big three guys yeah we're
the big three guys the basketball Baron
Davis hasn't made that face since he
banged it on CareLink oh he had to
Kirilenko face the Kirilenko Dunphy baby
we trying to get you in the Expendables
man but your reaction time your reaction
you know baby could be an action star I
thought big baby got arrested for all
that marijuana stay wish I do basketball
for real yeah they keep trying to that
three-on-three League I want to sketch
in this right here so your your show
making a murderer that kid Brendon yeah
I guess his appeal for the Supreme Court
was denied so that he got out I don't
know anything about this guy do you know
do you know what may I know you talked
about him a lot oh my god chin what the
[ __ ] he doing so Brendan was a kid that
they thought was in on it right and he's
the one where he basically admits that
he helped out and he goes can I get out
of here and go ahead and my art project
they go [ __ ] your art projects and
you're gonna wait for life for murder
you remember that I was trying to get
out first I thought he got up for just
being so stupid they don't want him in
the prison but apparently he's not
getting out Wow damn he's looking older
too man
yeah denied that's the thing though like
we get like the staircase make your
murder name any of the other [ __ ]
ones all those big ones all those major
docks remember it's for entertainment
they're painting a story we don't get
all the facts and the Supreme Court does
I would imagine
I mean yeah exactly imagine that that
that's all like looked like when people
go what the [ __ ] and let's let's vote
for this and get the - cities out of
prison
I guess when you talk to people who are
in the know like no he obviously killed
like we know for a fact he [ __ ]
murdered her but they paint the story so
you know he this conflict creates media
that's what they want but see right here
says that a panel of judges in the
Seventh Circuit US Circuit Court of
Appeals ruled against them by saying
that he spoke freely after Miranda
rights warnings so he if he's like
somewhat like messed up in the head of
course he'll speak freely after like he
did it yeah after them are you might be
looking at very specific you know kind
of like guidelines and in which whether
the Supreme Court only can hear certain
exactly this reminds me like the
Commission like the you know when
someone like God you know didn't tap out
or whatever Commission doesn't even
bother hearing it because they're like
no the referee said this it's done yeah
so it could possibly be that if you
watch to and again I need all the facts
I'm not gonna base my decision just off
a documentary but if you watch it the
cops interview him he was super young at
the time definitely were like this is
what happened was it would telling me go
I I guess it was you want to do that
because of this you know that was that
was that that's where you see how
confessions can be absolutely core sure
but but and then also in the staircase
movie the guy the the DA the prosecutor
the guy who they brought in for a
forensics got fired years later seven
years later because they found out he
was making stuff up and putting in false
evidence Wow
and so that's how he got a retrial there
yeah retractors they ki convicted man
for life the guy spent 21 years in jail
they find out that he was innocent he's
just a bystander and that guy made up
all the evidence
what and that he was the same prosecutor
and forensic guy for Hamas was like or
the staircase guy and he goes like he
was hitting some saying the blood was
splattered there and it's just not true
all of it was he just falsified all of
it damn so they retrial him he got off
the staircase guy he had to he had to
admit to involuntary manslaughter but
because of that in those Isaac's he's
free Wow
crazy crazy some shade can you imagine
me and innocently go to prison
somebody's a bad dude man talk about bad
it's like that dude who the prosecutor
for the case for those Duke a fleet the
rape he knew what the [ __ ] was up he
knew and he got disbarred but what a
piece of [ __ ] I think it's cuz I want to
see a guy like that I think I go he goes
those guys bullied me in high school
trying to get him back that's literally
what it is but what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're talking about people's lives this
woman this woman this woman is one of
them do players mothers tough woman she
goes he had a he had a silver bullet he
thought it would get him ahead
politically and he shot it and he's
gonna and he's going to regret it for
the rest of his life because they sued
the [ __ ] out on I'm sure [ __ ] that guy I
have no mercy for those kind of guys I
get a pistol back gonna take a quick
break for it
let's go piss let's go pppp
should we go off just a think yeah let's
get some greens and get some that turkey
the turkey I don't think I could stuff
that let's get her CLE with your
psoriasis yeah can he turkey with my
psoriasis lean meat greens raw nuts [ __ ]
off
yeah come on bro but he gets rice hoots
alright a top Netflix executive was
asked to leave or he's fired because he
used the n-word he used it during a
thing where like there is they were
talking about sensitive words inside you
know certain certain comic comedian
things inside Netflix like using that
word he was just discussing that word
referencing the reference say the word
he got kicked out fine he did it twice
he did it twice though so one he said we
gotta be careful not to use something
like that just story is kind of like a
little trippy but apparently was ya
talking about that's that sensitive word
so he said that word a few times and
then after that I guess some people will
felt uncomfortable about it they told HR
you know don't do that anymore so then
he did it again at another meeting with
two black people out in a meeting but he
was talking well let's not water that's
let's get the full context
if yeah I'm I wanna defend a dude if
he's dropping and bouncing back but
that's weird but if he was going we you
know we are be sure not even then what
he does or taste their accounts the
incident that occurred several months
ago in Freeland needs the n-word during
a meeting with Netflix public relations
staff during a discussion about
sensitive words several people told him
they were offended by his use of the
full word according to him I think this
is complete [ __ ] he's not racist he
was just using the word because he was
talking about the intensive word and
just saying it should not get you
[ __ ] fired
you're talking with somebody's
livelihood I know it doesn't make the
world less racist when you take a guy
like that is obviously not racist for
using a word it doesn't make the world a
better place I'm not gonna offend them
too hard
I asked Fred 'ln again used the word a
few days later in front of two black
employees in Netflix human resource
department when they're speaking with
him about the poor incident if you have
people in your company that are saying
it's uncomfortable don't say it and it's
a pretty harsh word but do you know okay
but but no what I'm saying is that do
you deserve to have your [ __ ] career
destroyed because you're you said a word
when you're discussing that it's
offensive what are we talking about here
because what you're saying then is oh
I'm gonna make a world a better place by
getting this guy here because he's a
racist
no no I'm sorry you can say that word
not be a racist especially when you're
talking about it in context this context
means nothing it's ridiculous it's
[ __ ] you're talking about firing
somebody you're talking about you you
don't have a job anymore
you can't earn a living [ __ ] off this is
ridiculous really yeah I don't know if
he should lose his whole from livelihood
interest but now so like wish there's
more like detail I wish I knew the
context I'm not getting offense I hear
the context all I know stand in front of
two black people he can't be that smart
to be a high-level executive at Netflix
if you drop it but if he said he said if
he was saying stop but he would not stop
no yes it depending on the context
depending on the context like saying
when you're talking about sensitive
worse we shouldn't have this word we
shouldn't have this word and you say it
out loud but then people are offended
but
you know but then after meeting two
african-americans go listen dude we
don't know what that meaning I don't
know what the conversation was I know so
don't defend it so let's just say well
defend let's just say they don't know I
will say this let's say yeah let's say
we had a meeting in here and you kept
dropping the n-bomb and after we had two
african-american employees which I do
that I've worked for me come on you go
Brian we get your magic no don't use the
energies not you not me the n-word but
then the next week he goes back to his
listen n-word n-word n-word you like
what stuff yes man if you're dropping
the n-word but what I'm saying is if
you're talking about the word being
offensive say you're teaching a class
say you're talking about it in Netflix
and saying how often do we want to hear
this word and use it what word and you
say the word and it's contextual that's
not that's not being racist it's not at
all it is not being racist no it's not
behind all so you should lose your job
over it it's a bit depends on how it's
used a this mean if you're calling
somebody that okay then it's really a
problem we all [ __ ] know that but but
don't we all know as white males not to
use the n-word you know like even if I
had a why don't you what the meaning was
and that word was in there I would not
use that word effort fine but at the
same time you there are people that
could be a white male or a Chinese male
or whatever male and say the word in
certain context where obviously or no
they said this is a really offensive
word or they were talking about the
history of the word it's yes you can
talk about it and it doesn't mean you're
a racist I mean I don't let me let me
ask this when you read Huck Finn Mark
Twain's book and the use of that word is
in there and you were reading it out
loud to a class and it's an American
classic and by the way different and by
the way difference being used the word
by the way the Mark Twain was against
that you know what would basically Shane
ompletely [ __ ] how bad racist is a
grown man who's high who's in charge
it's completely depends know it's
doesn't goddamn is written how long
though how long was that book really
good but you so hold on where does that
book really in the 18 I was just up from
eighteen hundred's right yeah so you're
reading that in context this is a grown
man at what at fifty-five context too
but he's still dropping the word out of
his own words and imagination if they
were
they were talking about the word he look
first of all first of all you can say
that word and not be offensive and
racist I disagree
so you can definitely say that word if
your it fits in context but what they're
saying here is that and we don't know
the entire story but these people will
confront on letter so we're not
comfortable we're not comfortable with
that's like I'm Korean all right and you
say [ __ ] like say we're talking about
[ __ ] thing whatever right yeah and say
like you guys I it makes me feel okay so
I bar say in Vietnam a lot of times the
soldiers would refer to Vietnamese
people as gooks that's a historical fact
in the 70s it's a horse Oracle yeah 70
and I'm saying it now yeah but it
doesn't mean that I believe that that's
what I would call it be let's say you
said that right after chin goes hey I
get your point
yeah we not say that any morning but
yeah no problem tomorrow you come back
hey chin these gooks
and Chin's like what the [ __ ] so so in
my opinion every word is the meaning of
attached to it and every word is just
not when it can have word like three
words the context you put to it I just
and that's the bottom line not with the
anyway and if not then then what we're
doing is we're taking people who are
good people and we are demonizing them
and then then if you do that and if you
do that then what happens to the real
racist you know you're putting everybody
on the same level and you believe in
punishment no like don't say you're
taking a businessman yeah it was dumb
enough to keep using the words I don't
want him lose his job if you're using it
in context of people's cussing it in
context over don't lose your job over no
say one word and you didn't say one more
second time is second time no no more
than two or more there's more there's
been more instance well first of all we
don't know all the details so we're
getting a little so so we should just be
a little bit quiet but but at the end of
the day in my opinion there is a lot of
this [ __ ] that goes around would you
people get fired over over stuff that
they don't deserve I don't know other I
don't know other situations racist I
don't know yeah I know nothing about it
exactly nothing about it exactly so two
saves not a race
I'm reading there is that doesn't sound
like he's a racist well I don't know
okay I have no idea I don't know if he
is or if he is yeah
all right neither do you and we know he
got fired for using the n-word yeah and
I know and also he was it says it sounds
like he was talking about a sensitive
words where he got in trouble for and
and ever say Lord and was offended by it
it's it's from what I've read there this
point just becomes a human being to
human being like hey don't don't say
this it hurts my feelings it you know
whatever so any continue to do it that's
bad leadership it has a light thing I
think we live in a time when executives
and a lot of businesses fire people over
very very very little and I and I think
a lot of good people who are not racist
get fired I'm not talking about Roseanne
I'm not talking about certain things
like that I think that there are a lot
of examples where we are so sensitive
about this stuff and the the radical
left is so [ __ ] sensitive and you're
not really solving a problem and making
the world less racist or more fair this
way I just don't believe that I don't I
don't know if Netflix try to make it a
better world I just think like we can't
have this like we're a fifty five
hundred billion dollar company we cannot
have this like we've had employees
African Mango dude quit using that or
don't get [ __ ] what context do not use
absolutely got it here you worry if
you're using the n-word like that yeah
yeah that's that's kind of using it if
you're using it like you're saying those
those M words over there or something
like that
well yeah well no I mean no but if
you're in a meeting go hey guys let's
not use certain words like ninja light
in there like all right hey dude can you
say there and where do maybe don't say
the actual the full thing goes no prom
next meeting all right let's be so
that's not make sure we don't say
problem so he should lose his job or
he's being racist cuz he said it I'm not
saying he said I'm not seems racist I'm
say he's a little too comfortable with
the word we're taking an issue okay
there's you if it's multiple times then
we have a problem
then I we may be saying let's not use
this word and keeps dropping it over and
African Americans are in the meeting
yeah yes then we got a problem
so let's not use this word to use that
nobody should be fired for it if it's
multiple times yes you're out of your
[ __ ] no it's
you're out of your [ __ ] mind you guys
are out of your [ __ ] you know who would
say hey guys this is a sensitive issue
so let's stop saying this yeah and then
African Americans who suffered from the
word dobro don't use that he goes no
prom then the next day does that word
okay do you want that leadership in your
[ __ ] oh no dude I just think that at
the end of it he's not a racist guy but
you're saying not to use that word then
then and I use the word to be very clear
about it it doesn't make me racist no it
sees no you're missing the point
it's a poor judgment okay you got will
just you don't think it's poor judgment
be to keep using it I don't know I don't
know the context you just gave me yeah
not over and over and black people do
say that over and over again better you
know multiple cases they said it twice
well I mean and after them coming up to
say so don't don't say this worry hurts
our feelings or whatever you should just
not say it man I I don't know I don't
know that I don't know again I do not
know the details I don't know
I understand Brian's point though
because you're taking away certain
things if you're if someone's saying
something in context you're accusing him
of being a racist I get that I'm nothing
no I'm are you fine I'm with you as well
I'm sorry I'm for his lack of [ __ ]
but yeah don't be stupid and play that
if you're hurting people's feelings I'm
gonna have to let you go if your leader
this company oh so you're hurting so so
so when you hurt people's feeling what
the end with rates it's not only certain
words the n-word is a note if you're a
white male you cannot use the n-word in
any facet you have not earned the right
to use that word I don't care what
you're saying is that a man who says
let's not use this word can use it
that's offensive or you're discussing
certain words and you have the words on
the board or you're talking about one to
be very clear that then well no now
you've got some if he's going right
let's not use that word
that's different right thing saying
let's not see right but you can't say it
well multiple times I think we're
getting into real murky water skiing
words this one's not that murky to me
this one went black people in your HR me
and go dude let's not use the n-word
that
obviously you know these are saying
don't use the word period or don't even
say it out loud when you're saying don't
then I'd be like we kept doing it yeah
that nomination you know I got I don't
know the context I don't know the
context I think people are just just I
think people are on sex it for sure
political the political the public
square is just insane but we can't we
can't chalk that bill oh my god it was
so sensitive every time what I have
always talked about this environment
there is unforgiving in every in so many
ways like you can you can say one thing
innocently and lose your [ __ ] career
we know that I think and that's what I
grow in time anyway just doesn't get
brought up if using that meeting and
dropped it and then that Canadians came
out we're like dude don't use a toilet
[ __ ] my best yeah I don't think you got
fired by the time don't know about that
I think I think a lot of Corporate
America is is just insanely sensitive
about that yeah more who wrote an
article I wrote a an internal memo
because he was asked to basically about
trying to figure out why more women are
not in computer programming and he's
decided a whole bunch of really
interesting scientific reasons that are
really vetted and he just cited other
science he got fired for that oh whoa
whoa you know whoa he's not saying women
shouldn't be on he was giving scientific
reasons the science and presenting it
internally and he got fired okay this is
happening all the time
let be careful cuz you're [ __ ] next
mmm don't because you're next just don't
use the N word you should be like oh you
just be careful of all your language not
just the N word now your language bro
everyone sitive oh god yeah it was
losing Johnny artists like rose air for
being right there no should lose the
[ __ ] dog should do some reading my
friend I do Romanian dog you're too
involved
bro you don't do it I usually go look at
how crazy oh my god human resources
Aladdin a crime let's never eat us
entire just lies you home I'm not
talking about just Peterson that boot on
this way before Peterson give me a
little I know you have read be young
tell your so Duvall you're acting like
you're you're defending be careful how
you did I can't have an American or
white because I'll never never be too
careful how you defend corporate America
you're defending Cobra I'm not defying
corporate America no I'm agreeing with
Netflix he should lose his job okay
oh he should yeah all the details do you
good for you do you know I just said
that I do too you're saying according to
this what we have right now in front of
us like I think we agree that if you
[ __ ] that let's just move on this kind
of [ __ ] drives me up a [ __ ] wall
let's move on because we keep having
these arguments and it makes me nuts
it's [ __ ] ridiculous we know the
difference between a racist and a non
racist all of us do yeah I [ __ ] yeah
let's worry about let's worry about real
racist okay guys let's race exactly how
do you know he's not look make sure you
know but you're signing that anyways you
know moving on yeah you're next you're
next
I'm not everybody is all right Anthony
Bourdain they did a toxicology report
and apparently he had no drugs and no
alcohol and it's know he had a shitload
of alcohol he said no really
this is off he had a shitload of alcohol
that's not what I read Johnny a shitload
of alcohol not what it says here I know
what is this sort when did this come out
yesterday
go to Google Anthony Bourdain alcohol
system dead no trace of alcohol it says
says the problem came in yeah this one
says well Keith so Washington Times on
how reputable they are Bernie pretty
reputable they say no narcotics or
alcohol in a system when he died there's
more it erupted cool NECN
says Bourdain had alcohol in a system at
time of death so there's mixed reports
then and then Good Morning America this
morning's idiot alcohol no no card no no
Joe thing is even out
although you know it's like he still
killed himself you know so strange I bet
you he wouldn't know I did you know that
sounds like here see that pad alcohol no
narcotics that's in Chicago at the NBC
you know so maybe you don't have the
wrench effects I got a different thing
right yeah so the French coroner says or
the French French toxicology report said
that he had nothing in system but most
of it I heard to see no drugs or alcohol
that's what I heard off the bat man this
morning when I woke up they said he had
like a crazy amount of alcohol not that
at maddox I'm gonna kill yourself you're
gonna [ __ ] get pretty ass
you can't blame anybody it's just it is
what it is but then his girl posted a
picture of her with a dude yeah dude do
you know someone somebody somebody
emailed me who I've had contact in the
past and he's had suicidal issues and
you know what he said he said to me he
goes he said like how cuz I was talking
about it like being on fire and he goes
it's not really like that he said you
know I'm funny like I was like so maybe
she yeah like you know some people can't
take it and he said he goes have you
ever been in a sauna because you ever
been in a sauna and you get to a point
where you're where you're not able to
take the heat and you're gonna panic he
goes for me it felt like that but that
was my existence and there was nowhere
to go happy and I was like [ __ ] I put
that in context you know you you know
you ever been in a sauna where it's so
hot you're like I gotta get out of here
I'm gonna [ __ ] die alright this sweat
lodge one time like that I read that
when I heard that I was like it's so
unbearable that the only way out is you
know I can't understand unbearable I
mean that's mental illness that might be
that might be depression for some people
well obviously it is and then something
set them off with it yeah well or
something like that but they say this is
a girl this psychiatrists saying that
it's the scary thing is that suicide is
a rational decision right so you're like
there and you go I can't get out I can't
get it I can't I can't go anywhere else
it's the only way it's the only way out
which is and they're also say um if you
do feel that way like the best thing you
can do from what I've talked to just
certain people who hit me up is talk to
somebody like talk to the person I'll
talk to them is what everyone says yeah
no drugs just talk to them just you know
medication of
yeah sure one saves a little lives I
believe that I believe that Prozac and
things like that do you can I guess I'd
have one more sad one I don't know if
you guys we've talked about this
recently I see a Pantera the only group
that I didn't talk about it remember
Alice we're talking about favourite
heavy metal bands who I saw in concert
yes and Pantera's the only one that I
didn't get to catch catching concert our
favorite metal bands you know seeing
them know so did ya
the drummer died he only had 54 well you
know his brother died - he was murdered
his brother died back Daryl but he died
how some crazy military guy just shot
him in the head during a show
what and that brown the fighter was
there during that show why a military
dude just like yes like PTSD simple or
just crazy or just crazy PTSD he shot a
militant thing at the concert at the
concert yeah so two brothers died tragic
how did he die drugged early I don't
know for a fact they think it's a heart
attack I'm not I tell you my doctor goes
my doctor doctor tell you this he goes
through my heart arterial branch no and
he goes some I go what are you doing he
goes I'm just looking for compromises in
your arterial ranch you gonna have
everything could be perfect cholesterol
and everything else to drop right
because you have a compromise you have
like a little thing and it's called the
Widowmaker and he goes on he goes
between 45 and 55 you're gonna lose some
friends this way and I was like I had a
buddy that I scare from that recently
yeah super scary I don't passed out and
then went there and they said that with
the do I know yes how do you treat
yourself for it then you get checked so
you can do a couple things one long fly
you can do it [ __ ] you too with that yep
yep you can do I know I've been asked to
do this you take you drink and die and
they can take a 3d image of your heart
they can see your heart they can see
everything they can see all the plaque
everything like literally a literally a
3d image and you can get exactly how
much plaque you have in your valves if
there's anything like that or anything
and they and my friends as doctors
always asked me to do what I haven't
done yet oh geez yeah it cost you like
900 bucks it'd be worth it though and
the other thing to do is I think you can
do certain certain things with sonic
sound
where did he die Jim wait
that is how oh yeah his house in Las
Vegas man he just died of a heart attack
yeah they think nothing's official yet
right my friend junior died like that he
died at 46 45 just died driving his car
in great shape work about all the time
drum which is used in pretty good shape
yeah tres Barker I mean I know a lot of
top professional athletes Travis
probably the best shape person I know
Vinnie Paul's on the bigger side most of
the deal but the cardio - yeah those
drums like for sure piece is the one of
the best drummers I've heard the bass
really double bass you know
yeah the feet it's awesome you watch the
stage and I'm playing forever it's crazy
loose that chin when he went yeah sad
well let's keep from the Goldbergs died
Jackson as well I was gonna ask if you
knew him no okay never saw him he had a
small role in there I don't know buddy
black man what he died from was a
suicide it might have been he was in a
sober living house I think he had a lot
of in the past which was plenty that is
so young you and I have kids we know
what that would be like oh my god you
know sometimes I think it was like with
Sean Penn's brother Chris Penn when you
do a lot of cocaine your heart expands
apparently or it weakens your heart and
you can have a heart attack later on
yeah cocaine is the drug of choice these
days for these kids dude how about how
about what he's on hey how about I'm in
Portland and guy goes me and Steve
you're talking to this dude these kind
of guys one guy's got like tattoos all
over his body with these huge ears with
the plates in it and I'm alright and
another guy's just loud and big and he's
like he goes man we're gonna go do
cocaine and I go oh oh
how'd you set that he goes people he
goes dude it's crazy here though the
[ __ ] we're getting here is a fire it's
fire I goes that no what do you mean
like speeding no no it's [ __ ] amazing
I don't know what's going on but the
[ __ ] we're going so we're gonna go do
that [ __ ] if you guys want to come I was
like I gotta wake up at zero desire to
[ __ ] yeah I don't want to [ __ ] with my
heart but thank you so much everyone
that Jenna yeah
I'm half-horse see he's looking at oh
wow listen you're under all oh I'll bet
you that's what he does on the weekends
oh hell no you that's you of all people
kratom boy stay away from below no it's
like we watch it bro look at me right
now no I like pills I don't wanna first
listen I promise you listen up
not cocaine listen up listen the [ __ ] oh
yeah by Donna yeah listen up and I'm not
a drug guy how much [ __ ] let me put it
this way a bunch of blue I think we're
starting her out what he does he was
trying to figure out what he does in the
weekend look at me right now now you
know I'm not drug guy right I can say no
when I when that guy goes it's really
good blow in Portland I had to take a
minute I had to take a minute because
when people that look at me I almost
want you to I want to go get some pure
statistic because you are you up all
night now you just feel like 1 million
dollar it's put it's Portland where that
weird uh for less places that sure is
but you guys go didn't go to the voodoo
donuts and I didn't go to the bird
brother last thing and now that you
mention it I'm pissed I didn't go I
think that's what was horrible was it in
Vancouver I hope it's Portland for sure
he was Portland voodoo doughnuts but god
damn it it's Portland see what happens
whenever you don't go to the other where
I was I said to Brendan I go I wish we
could just do the road together hey
listen to this
don't do it come on tempt it for you
just to try a couple of lines I'd have
to get it from like you legit [ __ ]
swell yeah obviously but but I'm and I'm
sure that's out there but and of course
I don't I'm not saying you should do
this but I have this morbid desire for
you just just think you can understand
but I would never do that to you because
I'm afraid you would be like wait a
minute it's expensive habit away isn't
he got money that's I'm afraid now that
you guys talk about it people are gonna
want to send you stuff so be careful
coke yeah do not know hello that shows
cocaine's not good no please don't
please when I'm in Oklahoma where
there's nothing to do bring go down so
please do cocaine no just kidding
and nothing again don't do it with speed
the problem is a lot of times it's cut
with speed I don't have my covers not
like Evers you're gonna poo I don't like
peppers huh I don't like uppers what
else yeah you don't know what you're bro
you know what you're missin you know how
you ever drink coffee and feel like
damn I feel hot yeah like the day is
here nice I want you to [ __ ] in
quadruple that and then add another four
times bad French thank you me too no I'm
not I'm saying don't do it but I'm
saying do that's how you fear saying do
it there's a fait there's a joke and I
camera we said I said problem with doing
blows you'll sit there with your friend
and you'll start a business together and
you'll be serious about it let's sell
candles why the [ __ ] aren't they selling
candles was last time you were in a
candle shop exactly dude why don't we
come up with wax I got a friend who can
make wax how much does it cost to make
wax before you know what you're writing
a business plan they say wallet didn't
then you're like this you're like you're
my friend I did blow one time there I'll
say it with my neighbor she was like she
was doing blow and I was like I was
young and I was like how old I don't
know I was probably 49 now I was yeah I
was probably like 31 or something and
she and she was there and she was my
neighbor and she was kind of hot but not
at all and then she looked at me it's
because you're so cool and I go thanks
and she was already high and I go I was
like damn my music was playing she's got
uh oh yeah aren't you happy we're
neighbors and I was like making our head
pulled out my coke dick and and then we
[ __ ] hard to [ __ ] on coke it is it is
but this stuff was pure and my dick
could have cut it dies and kids I'm
saying a lot of stuff right now but I'm
just I'm having a coke flashback right
now don't do blood you don't want some
good times with it huh that's like he's
working for a corporation so much I talk
about everything I don't do cocaine
anymore and I don't recommend it it's
been many years I only got it a handful
of times that's the truth chin you've
been on a still went back on it but I
don't take as much and I honestly want
to do less not because I want to try CBD
something for back pain CBD CBD pills
yes Sarah gave me like one of where's
your back pain CBD pills right your
glutes a lot of people giving me
information to oblige that's in your
head CBD is not good or do some
exercises for something they're saying
that it really helped me your brain is
tricking your body to think it's just a
I've had three people do it with real
back back pain and it worked and it
worked for me so I'm a big bulging Jeff
Lauren Lauren land down [ __ ] hey Lauren
also get off the sauce or it's a bulging
disc and you got real problems
there's do you have something I forgot
what's called lose that
not a bulging disc Oh hoping I'll do it
though if it's where you had that no but
you will [ __ ] you fix that by bulging
discs no not with therapy anything I
don't think so really
what about tractions after that out you
know I'm saying you're not going there
especially with the pinch of the nerve
oh thank you do all the [ __ ] glute
raises you want yeah but this help me
what else you got - all right the next
one is this at a luxury Lodge in the
reception area and this is in South
Africa a pack of hyenas 14 hyenas killed
a kudu you guys what kudos are like to
see this little deer yeah like a big big
deer with horns so this is their lodge
and this is where people there's what
people hang out
holy [ __ ] why is tonight so they got it
early early in the morning that's when
the hyenas got him so this is I'm
walking to the lodge do they know what
the red to hit yeah
they see blood everywhere so why is this
thing expanding they probably thought
someone died what's the other buzz holy
Oh looks like a straight murder scene oh
my there's the kudu in right in the
middle of the lodge the reception area
how did I know this 14 hyenas I guess
they saw it as they got there and then
they all took off but then oh so they
couldn't eat it because they took off
yeah because they saw a second haters oh
that's a serious kill now would you uh
would you eat some of that kudu I don't
know what it is it's like a big deer yes
malicious deer do you know how [ __ ]
gnarly are hyenas yeah they don't [ __ ]
around and Lee asked first how keep
zooming out you how much do they eat of
that otherwise I only kind of [ __ ] him
on yeah the top part for sure take the
skin off Jesus but this is work I almost
let him eat it hang out yeah I'd let him
finish right get alone gets a call I
don't live censor my real you these ants
scurry I'm on suppose you are no one's
in there because it's not as a bad look
for the know they heard this huge like
commotion animals going crazy they had
to run by and check it out dirty look at
the entrails look at this [ __ ]
and all the paw prints it's not they're
very sloppy forget all the pulp rings
whoa those are blood they're sloppy the
bad look for the resort huh
sorry Kudo hazard sorry to use the back
exit we had 14 hyenas eat a [ __ ] kudu
live sorry I apologize sorry about the
kudu blood it reached up around the kudu
[ __ ] as you getting eaten alive you
should have been there are entrails
if you smell blood and poo it's just
death it's just Kudo don't worry we'll
give you a comp dig for two free drinks
if you can get over the shuttle eat that
kudu though although you don't to eat
from behind is cuz hyenas have rotten
mouths oh eight a lot of carry hyenas
her [ __ ] nor they got terrible mouth
bad breath that's an Africa support
system yep cut yeah yeah it's not happen
in San Diego know what else get Jim
alright this is a I think Variety
reported that Johnny Depp uses a
earpiece he pays a audio engineer to
feed him his lines through an earpiece
because he's a contra memorize all the
lines
that's a report by variety
however Johnny Depp says the reason to
use is because he does this this is his
quote I've got bagpipes a baby crying
and bombs going off over the earpiece he
says it creates truth so when he's in a
scene where he wants to look you know
like he's really focused or whatever he
has this stuff playing in his ear to get
him to that moment to them does that
mean he's right I don't give a [ __ ] what
he chooses Johnny oh he's only been
doing it for ever at one of the highest
levels of all time I mean even if he did
its own feeding them lines okay for you
guys Hayden put that earpiece in and
we'll feature the same line yeah exactly
you pull this off exactly
let me see you do [ __ ] Edward
Scissorhands with that thing in you're
incorrect [ __ ] off
correct correct I mean let me see
whatever your medicine you do willy
wonka and [ __ ] and play that guy in
width of ear peon that's [ __ ] schmuck
that's right that's exactly right like
it doesn't matter like you you've done
some acting you have an appreciation of
how hard like come on I don't know you
guys memorize lines
it's not even about it's not about lines
that's a good example it's more about
what he said it's about the behavior
it's about the character it's about your
your your the emotion behind the lines
right again I can say something and you
don't feel it I can see that I can just
look at you and you feel something
memorized in an hour and 20 of stand up
Jim
that's what I'm saying well you you guys
develop that you guys created those
lines I'm saying when you guys do acting
stuff I don't know how guys memorize
these because what is the intention
behind the line what are you doing and
then you also get the script for a while
so we keep going over you that's tribute
yeah and you run lines before hand is it
where Johnny Depp fans obviously yeah
well one more you did yeah one more all
right
Saudi Arabia finally ends its ban on
women dry literature and my mother
couldn't drive except that's crazy
bill long accidents etc hey let's go up
five hundred percent sir
Jim why do you think Asians get a bad
rap when it comes to driving well first
of all we have smaller eyes there's
number one number two we're coming from
Asia it's just different I think that
smaller eyes alight see no I mean that's
where the stereotype came from and then
plus I have seen my parents my mom
driving I get it yeah my dad's great it
might be a little more careful way too
careful a little cautious yeah
generation the younger generation like
like there's no Asian NASCAR f1 for
announcers now with the younger
generations of everybody like you know
used to be when I was growing up you
Indian people from India we're just
typically not that athletic and not bad
you know and now I'll do my shoes well
then I do my shows people from India and
Pakistan come on they're still be the
case okay Jack's not athletics how many
well this might be tougher how many uh
how many yes sir how many how many gold
medals how many medals did India win in
the last Olympics no no unless there's
Chris let's just cricket they went in
[ __ ] isn't that interesting a billion
people one yeah but how many how many
are brilliant computer programmers now
oh [ __ ] a shitload of them how yeah a
lot of innovation they don't really
emphasize sports
or not you know it's come yeah then they
will what notice is in Atlanta win 50
more so far it is as only 128 metals net
24 in 24 limpid games so 24 so not a lot
not a lot so nothing in the last woman
right
what 2016 India national field hockey
team so they want bronze and silver in
2016 and what but day but I don't think
that really focus like rest now like
wrestling wrestling in gymnastics well
wrestling because in the seek in the
Punjab wrestling is a big thing among
the Sikhs you got some good wrestlers
there what's all the picks 2017 that's
right because they're there it's a
tradition I guarantee that those guys
are probably Sikhs I'll find skiing
three gold Wow dancing Indian on the
whole again so much India we should go
to India man god there's so much to see
in India oh my god and of Zartha
this is Special Olympics Brendan don't
[ __ ] I'm not doing it laughs there's
a one hole in 2017 bro you're googling
skills I know that's where I got draw
the line right hold on India and the
special in the Special Olympics when
Alpine Skiing I don't get this that
means 37 you know what that makes sense
they won 37 goals in special my series
are spent their focus in on the Special
Olympics instead of the regular Olympics
well then the world Winter Games a 137
maybe the pulling a ringer I mean means
they have a regular dude in the Special
Olympics
oh god that'd be [ __ ] up yeah alright
well
they have a kids almost sold out for
Italia Hall to mine just but I was
confused the only Thursday Friday
Thursday Friday Saturday Thursday Friday
Friday we shoot the special Thursdays
one show they were too shy to show two
shows did I take a long break buddy
hello buddy thanks doing show right yeah
come see me in Syracuse come see me in
Tampa first July 6 & 7 it's next week
Friday 30 it is and then come see me at
the Tampa improv and then come see me
way next weekend this is hurricane Ocean
July 4 obably 14 15 something like that
alright whatever that Friday Saturday's
yeah no it's 13 14 13 14 July 13 sick
you said no and I'll be at Gotham comedy
club July 2 well how about that adding a
show just one night a yeah just to get
up to speed so you know go into the show
you're gonna find in New York City then
then take a train to Syracuse I'll slide
Syracuse train of seven hours fly there
the next day too bad yeah you know the
hotels right across the street if it's a
lot you know the a loss yeah that's all
there was a you have fun up there uh in
Cherokee Casino July 7th come laugh with
me our stand up and then I'll stick
around for the fights you see 226 the
ticket gets you into the comedy show and
the fights that thing's almost sold out
July 7th tricky casinos and then after
I'm in Spokane Washington Spokane is
what is that gin the just fall into the
same dates as you was that the 12th to
the 14th I'll look it up right now
oh you doing that spoke well through the
14th spoke in Wow July 12 three days
three Thursday Friday Saturday smokin
Thursday Friday Saturday July 12th
through the 14th and then Austin cap
city those tickets on sale
almost all the shows are now sold out
already so jealous that's August 2nd
through the 4th first time at cap sees
some tea fat cake I'm sitting for Brian
and myself and we'll see you guys at
Chicago together pace if we don't kill
each other
this who the fire kid we're out